that reminds me of the story i saw about
the reality tv star that started selling
their farts
did you hear about this yeah and then
she got a heart attack because and then
she she farted so much that it gave her
like gastritis or like stomach problems
that she thought she had a heart attack
and had to go and a knee
and so an amazing story yeah so like
and so after that she's just like you
know what i should stop selling farts so
what does she do she starts selling
farts as nfts are you serious i'm i am
deadly serious
this is this is like a month old news by
the time you're watching this yeah it
was very [ __ ] dumb it was so stupid
i'm seeing this and i'm just like you
know what can we go back to black mirror
can we please go back to black mirror
that that that is the future that i want
you know
all these game companies as well being
like nfts we like them and it's like
yeah because you can make money from
them
because you can rip us off
yeah so that that yeah i don't know i
just sometimes you just sigh at the
future sometimes wait hold on hold on
back up how do you she's selling her
farts as an nft i i don't know how that
works i don't you know i maybe she's
selling a picture of her farting into a
jar isn't it maybe she farts on the
keyboard
and then like you know there's something
like that and then like use letter e
yeah
you know how like in the movies right
when someone's typed in their code on
the pc
you know you blow the dust [ __ ] on it
you see the fingerprints yeah basically
what happens is that she just farts on
the keyboard and whenever the fart is
like traced on the board she types out
the shittiest ouija board yeah maybe she
has
maybe she has a fart scanner where it
digitizes her farts into bits and that
gets that gets converted to an nft which
can be put on the people
binary
i hate the internet so much i mean they
literally they recently like japan just
made a screen that you could taste oh
yeah the lickable screen yeah the liquid
concepts so it's all concept melons like
salivating
i never want to lick a screen
it's like half the the good foods
because of the textures yeah what i want
to know is like
this this screen like the screens are
like dirty enough as it is and you're
telling me that there's going to be
people constantly licking the screen
are you gonna have to like clean it
every time you have like a single have
we not learned anything from this panda
that that is literally the worst idea in
the world
why did you have to announce it now i
bet i bet jojo fans would be happy
that's like oh my god
gerardi right
finally i can leave out my dream
of leaking sweat
jesus christ
oh my god someone oh i just can't get
over the [ __ ] fart
it's pretty bad
i wonder i just want to know how it
works now
i don't know i i don't know i i thought
we would please google this actually for
us can you google can you google fart
nft yeah how how this works please
i thought humanity had hit it slow when
bel delphine uh was selling her bath
water
who knew that that was just the
beginning
that was she was trying to warn us of
the future i think a lot of people sell
their bath water now right
that was but the genesis
of the
oh apocalypse god yeah i mean i'm i'm
sure a lot of people sell bath water now
i'm sure oh yeah i'm sure
no no
i'll sell it i'll be honest i i don't
browse only fans so much so
it's so much i mean i
[Music]
yeah i don't know what people are
selling on only fans i don't know if i
want to know what people are saying on
early fans yeah if this is the kind of
[ __ ] that gets leaked yeah i thought
that when i saw the bathwater thing i
already thought that was ridiculous but
like even before that like there was
those places that were selling like you
ever see those like places that were
selling like cans filled with like air
yeah like the oh this is this is a can
filled with hawaiian air and i'm like
really
how did you get that air
did you just go to hawaii and go
like that
yeah just open the jar yeah just open
the shop ship them back i guess ups well
i guess how is that different from
spring water right yeah all right
but spring water makes more sense i
cannot understand why someone might make
an argument i don't give a [ __ ] i'll
drink it
you know i guess some people
picky they you know they don't want it
but normally the whole bottled water is
just like tap water with they just add
like a bunch of [ __ ] minerals right
yeah [ __ ] yeah i mean minerals
i mean elements
i mean element zero not incorrect yeah
two shots of lead
i mean it's like beauty products right
where beauty products like they market
they market the story to you as like oh
we got this we we got this product from
like the
the mountains of the himalayas where
like the only like the freshest tree
grows or something like that but it's
just someone in the in a [ __ ] lab
that made it yeah and they put they
stuck a label on it you know it's pretty
much it's no different so you know i i
haven't done enough my research on
where spring where bottled water
actually comes from i don't care
no i don't care
i have no it was the very
noise of nose no
i'm like man i like i will say you have
dismissed that argument any faster
do you care no i just want to know
those documentaries where it's like
nestle yeah where they just go into like
towns of america and just take all their
drinking water and then just sell it as
bottled water because they add like i
don't know like a label to it they had
like a one
zero milligram of chlorine or something
and then they're like now it's treated
water it's no longer tap water yeah what
wasn't like a massive
controversy um in england at least was
the fact that dasani um so dasani is
still in america if i if i remember
correctly
but the reason the sani is not sold in
england anymore because there was this
massive controversy where dasani
marketed it as you know fresh spring
water but it got found out that they
were just selling bottled tap water well
the tap was coming from a spring or
something anyway yeah but the the
obviously the people in the uk are very
i don't know how to explain it stuff
like that really pisses british people
off right the fact that like you would
try and sell us something that is just
so basic is something so much i was
wondering if if it's spring water
but it's connected to a tap and that
spring water is coming out of the tap is
it spring water is a tap water it's a
spring task [ __ ] sage it's just tapped
springs
we've entered the water metal right okay
i'm i'm going to bring you a step deeper
in the water okay okay so onsen culture
in japan right are you gonna tell me
that every single onsen water is like is
is every single onsen we go to just you
know fresh from the earth or is it just
like how where does that water come from
it's from the ground but it's through a
tap yeah
is it so what are you doing
is it hot springs or is it just
it's just tap water it's just is it are
you just taking a bath in tap water like
everything no
no
because tap water has to come from
somewhere right
a spring perhaps
i think tap water implies that it's like
the grid the national system
right yeah not not the [ __ ] thing
you're taking on bathroom guys because
because i see some onsen uh some onsens
have like the water get delivered to
them by trucks right yeah not not tap
water but they get they get it delivered
by trucks and i think well
is it like
i don't know the onsen is
from what i understand is like it's the
stuff in the water like the minerals
from like the whatever they dig out the
[ __ ] so so there's so there's a clear
difference between an onsen and a
centaur which is a bath house
right acento is just hot water it's no
there's no minerals in it it's not it
doesn't have like any of like that you
know natural stuff that makes you you
know makes it healthier yeah yeah and
then an onsen is the stuff that is like
mineralized like from the [ __ ] ground
like onsen water yeah right but i think
most people just assume that like oh
bath house equals onsen which it doesn't
yeah yeah it's two different things yeah
because like i i do notice depending on
the onsen we go to like the the
water is like very different depending
on where you go oh yeah there's like
there's like
30 different types of ridiculous
yeah because it's all just different
makeups right yeah like like the acid
one i went i went with chris into an
acid onsen
and then
the one we went to last week yeah